plutôt que de regarder la télévision
fellini préfère parler à son chat on
changer une ampoule sergio leone nuit ne
se cache plus de rien il déteste
absolument toutes les télévisions
privées
quentin marcello mastroianni et snob son
petit écran et il avoue qu'il n'entre
jamais plus dans une salle de cinéma
sauf pour voir ses films en première
projection
mais quelle mouche a donc piqué les
grands du cinéma italien déstabiliser
oui l'argent est ailleurs déprimés oui
des auteurs se font rares ils sont usés
et dépassé par les événements oui la
télévision des bords leur fils depuis
dix ans je ne dirai quel comme je veux
que me seconde je connais à tuer le
cinéma et avait un jeu où il en aurait
pas cette mérite cet honneur car avant
lui n'avait déjà pas mal d'autres qui
avaient fait la télévision privée et en
plus c'est sakhir je le suivais métabief
il n'y a pas de loi comme il ya en
france et il y avait une volonté
politique
alors ça n'a pas aidé sergio leone
déterrent la hache de guerre et il se
bat contre silvio berlusconi
une procédure judiciaire est engagée il
réclame 18 millions de francs le titre
de son film le bon la brute et le truand
diffusé récemment sur canal 5 n'a pas
été maquillé ce qui arrive parfois
mais il s'en est fallu de plus
jamais rien dire on a passé les films
dont la coupe et les 40 minutes et alors
les procès c'est normal c'est un procès
contre contre loivre même c'est une
bataille que vous menez tout seul contre
lui ou alors vous êtes appuyé par un
deuil familial
il y a beaucoup
des amis politiques l'heure
ce procès très difficile à votre avis
qu'est ce qui a fait le plus de mal au
cinéma italien la crise la paresse ou
berlusconi en italie c'est la télévision
générale elles apparaissent
je crois pas que de l'eau ce collier en
principe il signe en faute du côté de la
télévision mais c'est le complexe de la
télévision c'est pas venu il passera sur
conan ching wan talibans non le je crois
qu on en en train de le vendre mais à la
télévision publique à l'ars hype clichy
et qu'y trouve-t-on d'ailleurs scola
fellini antonio rossi
vous connaissez francesco outil qui est
d'ailleurs reçu le grand prix de la
ville de nice cette année valentine
ursini et roméo constantini ces noms
vous disent quelque chose du team
italien eni c'est terminé on va entrer